un écrin préservé d'architecture
médiévale pour les Journées européennes
du patrimoine la commanderie des
Templiers dévoile ses secrets une
manière de découvrir ou redécouvrir ce
lieu emblématique du 12e siècle c'est un
lieu en effet exceptionnel du territoire
c'est pour ça qu'on l'ouvre pour les
Journées du Patrimoine puisque en effet
habituellement on est ouvert le premier
dimanche du mois sur programmation et
donc c'est pas
accessible en visite libre
habituellement vous pourrez vous rendre
compte de ce qui était une commanderie
templière avec ses 28 m de long et ses 8
m de large la chapelle impose son
architecture gothique au domaine datant
du 13e siècle elle a été l'objet de
plusieurs restaurations celle de 1971
avait laissé les murs nus sans enduit ni
peinture la dernière en date a redonné
vie au décor ce qui est intéressant ici
c'est de la revoir après réouverture
donc elle a réouvert en 2012 après
restauration et vous pourrez découvrir
la restauration qui a été faite à savoir
la peinture les peintures murales voilà
et les vitraux qui ont été nettoyés créé
par l'ordre du Templier pour protéger
les pèlerins en Terre sainte le site se
visitera tout le weekend en Entrée Libre
l'occasion de replonger dans 9 siècles
d'histoire